jessyca perrito speaks out for the first
time about her divorce from Mike Schuh
at the Shahs of Sunset Star filed for
divorce from her husband on November
20th following the news Mike's rep told
et quote two years ago before they were
married Mike made a terrible mistake and
cheated on Jessica she recently
discovered a text message and he came
completely clean to her he feels so
terrible jessica is the most amazing
woman in the world but Jessica tells et
exclusively Mike's reps claims are not
true that she found text messages from
before they were engaged until as recent
as July 31st she adds it was not just
two years and one person that is not the
case he cheated on me with multiple
girls since separating from Mike on
August 1st jessica says it's been a mix
of emotions she says for the first month
I was in complete shock and really
depressed crying in my house all day and
then I picked my stuff up and left I've
gone through worse things in my life I
beat cancer I'm not going to let some
guy get the best of me